moi c'est rosalie mais tout le monde
l'appelle rosa là c'est mon père qui
vend des livres dans le monde entier
mais il vraiment passé pour être père je
ne suis pas fier d'afficher toile les
ados
quand je pense c'est un âge vache -
grotte à deux boutons plein la gueule
du coup j'ai décidé de vous donner une
petite leçon de ce qu'ils font là mais
tu sais papa ma classe de mer
on va aller une petite semaine avec nous
n'est pas la mort encore une hausse qui
sait faire de chasse quoi vous êtes
répète c'est à nous de faire chez soi
c'est vraiment prouvé en santé ça fait
rire ça m'étonnerait pas puis les
gueules comme si quelqu'un retraite à
taux plein est et voilà ta vie tu peux
sortir papa on s'est occupés
c'était peut-être un peu violente
réunissait sur la vitesse sa sage aura
le foot
c'est bien bien à chiens et bien fait de
l'acheteur au sol tu portois bonjour
attrape en matière des plus
d'où l'option